I think not only was he struggling in the factory but
he would be stunned until late studying certain
dispensations of electronics he
does not put you to bed
or
we
would like us strange little together lille and he
helped her because she was sorry to leave him
alone
next to him the weight that he felt in
his chest was lightened  a little we must
always be practical if not only chatter
at the bar
scandalizes the door that opens with the
zero scheme how you can do it
and if you can make it understood
but in this way we can also do more
complicated things still yes of course
but only we say everything to  place
and why not morici tones as a thing but
manufacturers to be
silent cevoli all the same
and yet to a
16 that you can pray to everything
then we are starting the factory
but we can combine
the algorithms are a sequence of
procedures
so we do a lot of things that
are defined  faces algorithms
and if we do the block diagrams and
transform them into exact geometric figures
then we are saying that we can bend
to everything
then d  we have to try with all
helium damato
[Music]
love
we want to start with your
factory
that they do it in short network nothing
indeed instead one thing continued I know if it
was still subjected at night